I like your focus on visiting other
parts of the world that have a strong
scientific advancement happening that's
why we're here in China as one of the
reasons like we want to come to a place
in the world that has a very serious
scientific advancement happening and we
want to interview the leaders in those
fields and then share that with the
world and the USA is a very mixing pot
of culture so you've got to immerse
yourself in a very deep diversity of
cultures when you are in the u.s. in LA
and when I come to China I get to
immerse myself in the diversity of China
Chinese culture even though it's more
homogenized only Chinese mostly here but
still I get a completely different
cultural vibe being here and I think
that's really important for trying to
bring the world closer together so
you're doing a PhD in Caltech me coming
here for interviews and stuff these
types of moves are very important for
especially young people to do and
they're the tips yeah yeah the interview
to meet the cultures of people make
friends in the different parts of the
world then all of the media stuff it
seems like it doesn't matter because I
have friends I know that we have love
and friendship and collaboration across
the countries and the media is just
selling a fear and other nonsense
yeah